bonsoir les jeunes et bonsoir les les
vieux le problème est que le sida est ce
que quand un pote qui là bas après il
meurt et ça c'est chiant la blague qui
installe le malaise et ouais le sida
s'est installé le malaise on n'a pas
trop rigoler qu ce genre de sujet parce
que c'est juste hyper grave
par contre l'ensemble on peut lutter
contre c'est très simple alors sois tu
trouves un vaccin contre le sida
mais ça demande beaucoup d'années
d'études ou alors vraiment plus simple
en 10 secondes
j'utilise ça c'est une capote xxl mais
bon ça la sarre à un pote alors je vais
pas vous faire une démo mais c'est super
simple hein c'est un préservatif que tu
mets sur ton sexe et ça évite pas mal de
problèmes comme par exemple les enfants
à les réguler
on rigole bien sûr c'est vraiment bien
la vie dont vous voyez c'est pas si
compliqué de lutter contre le sida
il suffit d'avoir ça en permanence sur
soi un mois c'est là j'ai sur moi depuis
quatre ans ah parce que j'ai fait
l'amour sans capote un nom juste parce
que j'ai pas fait l'amour
mettez des capotes ou au moins une ça
marche aussi avec une bon c'est des yeux
mais quand tu es dedans c'est sympa moi
j'avais essayé une fois et j'ai des bons
souvenirs
donc mon message il est vraiment tout
simple certains pourraient le trouver
même banal mais sait jamais trop de le
rappeler à mettet des préservatifs et
fait l'amour fait beaucoup l'amour c'est
hyper important et soutenez le sidaction
allez ciao